Anthony obviously you and David have
like an MCU connection though you
haven't started together yet do you have
any advice for David now that he's going
into the Thunderbolts and we'll be
co-starring with Sebastian Stan
Sebastian is a very nice person don't
take his quietness and standoffishness
as him being mean or rude you just have
to warm him up a little bit you know
give them some almond butter and uh you
know talk to him a little bit he'll be
fine he'll be fine just give him a few
weeks and he'll be fine so Frank is he
here now ready to have some fun
hi guys how's it going
this seems like the fun room I'm excited
okay so um love this movie you're
filming in New Orleans in the summer
there is no person on Earth I would
rather be in New Orleans with than
Anthony Mackey you are like the
unofficial mayor of New Orleans what do
you take everyone to do well somebody
wouldn't hang out with me I'm not going
to say somebody would not hang out with
me I'm not gonna say who he says you
know you're a bit much Mackie that
sounds like we're fine I don't want to
hang out with you either
he said he would you mentioned where
where he would take people he said he
would take me to this like place for
music because he got because he got the
hook up
I'm Anthony Mackey baby and I was like
okay so and he never took me he said
he's gonna take me to the restaurants
never took me to the restaurants I was
waiting to go to the restaurant not true
and now so no you know I I I'm not true
yeah he was too busy learning his lines
and you know he's always on the phone
FaceTiming people who are you talking to
buckle get off the phone just
wow yeah why you got to deal with it
yeah
not facts okay
I wanted my unofficial mayor to guide me
through the city but it didn't happen I
always think about what I would do if I
were a ghost for a day
um what would you do who would you haunt
would you what would you do
that's a good question that's a very
good question who would I haunt
hmm
probably I probably haunt you just to
mess up dude there's eight billion
people in the world I know but it's like
I just want to see how you would really
raise so many people he's from New
Orleans so he's right he might not be
super spooked by the ghost but I just
wanna there's so many people you could
own I want to get my lick back for real
that's really what it is I want to get
revenge because Mackie there's so many
people no yeah I would call him and
maybe some other people but yeah Anthony
Mack is at the top of my list I would
haunt my high school girlfriend I was
the same it's over for my exes they're
getting haunted oh I'm haunting see I
don't have any accents to hunt oh bruh
there's nothing like hating your ex I
was my high school girlfriend you talk
about fuel for the fire boy everything I
do is for you everything I do I want you
to look at your boyfriend and go you
could have been him but you're not
that's what I want that's my goals in
life yeah you hear that Stephanie yeah
okay
look under your bed tonight
I was Anthony Maggie's high school
girlfriend
like everybody
um I am a giant Star Wars nerd so I was
loving that little guitar moment um but
it I went to like the dips the depths of
the internet and jahi I I don't know if
you've seen this you I've seen a few
like fan castings of you as a young
Lando have you seen this
I have not seen this but you get an s
curl you could be Billy D oh yeah yeah I
could see that I could see being a young
Billy D I mean we got to get you on some
uh protein though yeah
[Laughter]
no yeah I I
could see that I mean I love Star Wars I
think it's like dream what would your
character's name be like if you had to
make up a character's name
oh
John
John wow
[Laughter]
John Nero we have to get back to the
ship
lieutenant John Lieutenant the one
character in Star Wars is a regular a
regular day
that's why that's why it would pop
though yeah Princess Amidala meet John
that would be good yeah nobody will
forget you it exactly all right
forgettable that I'm Unforgettable oh
you would be the drunk Storm Trooper yes
John back on duty
[Music]
foreign